[Musik]
das sieht markus geholt und historische
zeichnet hat das ganze haus hat er
ausgerechnet ein mann eine frau ein haus
eigentlich ideale bedingungen für die
gründung einer familie
doch im oberen stock des hauses kraft
eine offene wunde aber schon dass man
die zur kultur mehr mitgerechnet und
rechnet immer noch damit
wie schmerzhaft ist es keine eigenen
kinder zu bekommen und was nehmen wir in
kauf und mit hilfe modernster
fortpflanzungsmedizin doch noch zum
wunschkind zu kommen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
dabei hat alles so schön angefangen von
sechs jahren feierten die damals
24-jährige sabina rinner und ihr mann
regie hochzeit also bevor madonna
minister für die entweder das maschine
war beim aufenthalt comics kaiser waren
die kaffee
das haben wir sich merken muss vorrangig
du bist wenig gesprochen
gesprochen wurde und noch sind die
braunschweiger wie das gold und die lage
luftiger höhe auf zuspruch dass ich das
später zwei jahre warteten sie
vergeblich auf eine schwangerschaft
sabin arena schien gesund man suchte die
gründe bei ihrem mann die untersuchungen
gibt eltern in der vermutung branche
rinner leide an einem hirntumor der ihn
unfruchtbar machen
danach wurden seine spermien mittels
funktionen untersucht den wahren grund
er kannte man erst nach mehreren
eizellen entnommen und in vitro
fertilisation befruchtungen im
reagenzglas aus und 7
ich bin jung ich bin gesund es stimme
alles und das aber ich bin schwanger
wurde und neue fenster sekunde
der zweite punkt sodass ich bilde mir
und tut sich die zu 51 prozent pa geburt
oder behinderte wird den beiden blieben
drei möglichkeiten
kinderlosigkeit adoption oder eine reise
ins ausland als auch in arena die
eizellen einer fremden frau implantiert
werden befürchtet mit den spermien ihres
mannes rossi
entstehen würde so ein kind das mit
sabine riemer genetisch nichts mehr zu
tun hätte darum macht mir das nichts aus
wie ist es für sie sagen dass ich danach
wieder richtig glauben also seit es ist
mit der adoption durch das vorgestellt
hat das höre grünen daumen
zur nationalität sondern es war eine
ehre und das ist ja und das ist auch ein
bisschen vorgang unterwegs und das ist
ja auch als auch meine ich weiß man
nicht wie jetzt dass die geräte zu
hindern zum beispiel da nicht das
implantat uhr naja was sie finden ja und
dann das der schiene was die alles
gemacht hat sich hockeyspieler punkt
unterschiedlich ist also grund option
ist das thema für sie bis jetzt konkret
also songs nach der wahl gibt und dies
noch stimmt nicht sagen
sprachen geht das nur das thema und so
ließ sich sabina rinner schon zweimal
drei zellen einsetzen und sie wurde
tatsächlich zweimal schwanger
also merkst du musik apps hat sich als
sexy und im zweiten mal auch nicht schon
immer so als ich habe dank sturm möglich
dass es einem passieren und das ist ja
das passiert so orange weiß nicht ob das
sehr wichtig sind
während mixas ronny machen wie kann ich
dich unterstützen
und da ist doch durchschnitt macht mich
nur einfach nicht selber machen wie man
weiß ja was wichtig ist dass eben
einfach mama bin angesehen und hans
genossen
dass man sich dann mal leise und und
damit das zimmer oder mögen ja es ist
anfang märz 2014
in knapp einem monat lässt habe ihn
erinnert sich im spanischen alicante zum
dritten mal eizellen einer fremden frau
einsetzen
im spital glarus erhält sie heute eine
infusion welche ihr die spanischen ärzte
in die schweiz mitgegeben haben ihre
beste freundin sandra begleitet der weg
zum wunschkind ist auch körperlich eine
tortur hormonbehandlungen mit
entsprechenden nebenwirkungen gehören
zum alltag von sabinerinnen die infusion
des spanischen fruchtbarkeitsklinik soll
die einnistung der fremde eizelle in
ihrer gebärmutter erleichtern
ich finde das super ich danke der x6
oder selber viel geld oder gegen sind
und ich war das bitter aber rasch
gefährlichkeit wiederfinden
fast alle wagen aus frau du die nächste
wollte ich zum kinder.de cargo auf der
welt dass man fünf stunden dauert es bis
die medikamente in sabines körper sind
um sabine abzulenken kommt auch ihre
mutter vorbei sie weiß hier siehst
stundenlang an medizinischen geräten zu
hängen
marion schmid ist nierenkrank jahre lang
prägte die dialyse ihren alltag einfach
das ist mir so unterstütze das ist ja
vor zwei monaten nur die marion schmid
eine spenderniere implantiert das
jahrelange leiden hat ihre einstellung
gegenüber der modernen medizin geprägt
mai auf dem zug ich bin die tour an
ich hätte noch richtig sind und du hast
es jetzt aufgebracht dass stürme
geordnet da bin jetzt geordnet sind
jetzt wie das mit der natur ins handwerk
hätten wir's majak organ für pflanzen
oder ein twitter werden dadurch
maschinen oder dabei ich stehe da kann
man china mit solcher tour
der schreitende fuß operieren muss man
sich ja so sieht es wichtig sie versteht
dass jedes mal ist die wichtigste und
natürlich habe und zudem ist es gut wenn
ihr in sachen juni also ohne die
positive stelliger und die unterstützung
wird nicht gutes buch
ich weiß nicht wie ich das möchte
sabine rist kaufmännische angestellte
ihr mann roche servicetechniker ihre
beiden löhne würden nicht ausreichen um
sich den traum vom eigenen kind zu
erfüllen befruchtungen im reagenzglas
werden von den krankenkassen nämlich
nicht bezahlt fünf erfolglose in vitro
befruchtungen liegen bereits hinter
sabine arena die nächste behandlung
steht gut bevor ich sehr viel also mit
hand an die sparer und minimal und ich
hoffe bei 100 prozent und habe mir
machen von angeblich google-treffer mein
name ist jeder froh mal wieder tüchtig
einbringen
das geld bringt
2 die gespendeten eizellen und ein
erster embryonen transfer kosteten rund
10.000 euro jeder weitere transfers lebt
mit 1800 euro zu buche es ist april 2014
trainers haben das geld für einen
dritten transfer in der schweiz ist die
eizellenspende im gegensatz zur
samenspende verboten
jedes jahr leisten darum schätzungsweise
1000 schweizer paare für den empfang von
spendern zählen ins ausland medizin
locker zu machen dass wenn man das habe
der schweiz
innovativ wir haben was auf dauer ist
schon durchs land das ich je gefahren
bin richtiger praxis ich das nicht pusch
praxis oder das ist eine schöne sache
einfach irgendein praxis ihnen sagen das
ist ja
schon zum dritten mal führt die reise
nach spanien in die hochburg der
europäischen reproduktions industrie
genauer nach alicante an der spanischen
costa blanca
diese organisiert da überhaupt wirklich
kompetent und das wird dir aus wo der
praxis organisiert
etwa 600 schweizer paare unterziehen
sich in spanien jedes jahr einer
fruchtbarkeitsbehandlung die hälfte
davon konnten diese klinik wo man sich
auf eine deutschsprachige kundschaft
spezialisiert hat von neun monaten
wurden einer spanischen spenderin
eizellen entnommen mit treasuries
spermien befruchtet und konserviert die
spenderin erhält für diese keineswegs
risikofreie behandlung lediglich eine
spießen entschädigung kennenlernen wird
auf kind seine biologische mutter nie
spaniens gesetz seit die anonyme spende
von sabina und roche den reformen von
einer klinikmitarbeiterin das gestern
zwei embryonen aufgebaut wurden
diese befanden sich am vierten tag ihrer
entwicklung und haben sich seit gestern
zu stetig wachsenden blastozyste
weiterentwickelt
wirst du gerne besser konserviert die
sind immer noch gefragt
das jetzt vom 02 es war nicht schön
erzählt die anderen drei aufzutauchen
mal richtig okay ich nicht gut gewesen
wären dann in den tee dann auf den 3 und
die sind ja wenn der song variant
sicherheit gibt es etwas besseres auto
[Musik]
sitzen gespannt
die gründe liegen die mitbestimmen wie
die ostsee oder sie mir eine sakrale und
was er sei nicht wichtig steht das ist
das wichtigste
nein das ist so nicht richtig
beide sehr schön dass man sage
entstanden ist dass ich wie so schön das
wichtig dass mit dem zweimal wurde
sabina rinner hier in spanien mit
gespendeten eizellen schwanger zweimal
hat sie die entlohnen in der
frühschwangerschaft verloren nach diesen
fehlversuchen gegen die ärzte hier in
alicante große zweifel an der qualität
der spermien ihres mannes sie aber denn
hier wäre jetzt nach dem prinzip versuch
und schaue ich hoffe ich möchte sie
nicht mehr also eigentlich muss die
kluft spanien kommen wenn ich okay das
ist okay mit denen kann ich abtreten
oftmals kommt es testen
aber ich warne was genau nachgeschaut ob
es mit diesem oder mit den meisten oder
mit
das ist ein glück sie würden schaffen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt direkt aus dem labor
durch diese schleuse unterschiede
weiße kugeln
warum
das ist nicht fair
mai
und dann gibt wie sie ließen dies nicht
raus stellen hauptstadt wochenlang
während reaktionen auslösen des lüner
vermeiden also kein sex in österreich
sport eine unter wasser
bild machen die wird es auch wieder ein
geschäft punkte
[Musik]
sie haben zwar zucht oder so dann kann
ich auch mit kleinen aber mit den beiden
embryonen die wir heute aufgetaucht
haben haben wir eine
schwangerschaftsrate zu erwarten um die
65 prozent wir müssen weiterhin mit
einem abort und risiko um die 15 prozent
vielleicht in ihrem fall dass ich schon
zwei worte gehabt hat er in richtung 20
prozent also jede chance hier mit dann
in neun monaten ein kind in die arme zu
halten werde zwischen 45 prozent und 50
mit einsatz von zwei embryonen
[Musik]
die arbeit der reproduktionsmediziner
ist abgeschlossen jetzt wird sich zeigen
ob auch die natur mitspielt ich habe
meine zeit für mich und co machen danke
dann ist es hat aber solange ab bis
unter das gottes plan
die sache reden wir von der berghofer
reden wo mitunter band also nicht laufe
der ausstellung und so aber mit ein paar
blätter so genannt werden was wir tun ja
sie sind jetzt für das gefühl von
schools dass margot
[Musik]
schon bald wird sabine erfahren ob sich
die embryonen in ihrer gebärmutter
eingenistet haben und den traum vom
eigenen kind in erfüllung geht
wunschkind teil 2 am nächsten sonntag
[Musik]